olá eu vim apresentar sobre o tema
só agora no brasil porque faltava no
brasil seja o país que existe a maior
reserva de água doce do planeta
é parece muito mas não é a água água que
existe hoje no planeta é a mesma quando
começou a existir surgir vida aqui na
terra mas estamos interferindo no ciclo
da água há muito tempo
flashes protegem rios inocentes mas cada
vez mais eles estão sendo mais
desprotegidos amazônia contribui para a
formação das chuvas mas estamos
desmatando e no cerrado
hoje não é assim que os nascentes de
bacias hidrográficas são 100 destruídas
eo desmatamento
você sabia que em quatro anos na
amazônia foram destruídos
o equivalente a 5 cidade de são paulo
se não tivermos florestas em pé
não temos água usamos água para tudo
alimentação banho esporte lazer higiene
sabe a descarga
normalmente é uma uma tocada da descarga
ela gastou 14 litros de água e um banho
de 10 minutos no chuveiro gasta 90
litros d'água
você sabia sob a calça jeans que alguns
de vocês provavelmente estão usando os
usando pra parar a ser feita ela teve
que precisou 7 mil litros d'água e o
carro que vocês vieram até aqui está
parado no estacionamento foi feito com
35 mil litros d'água ea carne que
provavelmente você
ontem um quilo dela foi feita com 15 mil
litros d'água
eu estou aqui está na hora de repensar e
evitar desperdício eu estou aqui para
encorajá los lutar por um mundo melhor
obrigado